hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown education front
and center in virginia's high profile
gubernatorial race former education
secretary betsy devos sheds light on how
curriculum concerns and a year and a
half of frustrations over school
closures because of the pandemic are
playing into the showdown in the
commonwealth and democrats still
struggling to reach a deal on president
biden's economic agenda fox news sunday
host chris wallace weighs in on the
negotiations and shares his thoughts on
former president trump launching a new
social media platform plus commentary by
new york post columnist carol markowitz
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you could
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm abby hornacek this is tucker carlson
and i'm jessica tarlov this is the fox
news rundown
friday october 22nd 2021 i'm lisa brady
he denies targeting parents but the
attorney general's federal action on
school board concerns has hit a nerve it
really does call into question the
motives and the reasoning for this type
of overreach and overreaction we speak
with former education secretary betsy
devos
i'm chris foster democrats in congress
are working through what's in their big
social spending plan how to pay for it
and for how long i guess i'm just
shocked
that
the debate over what is possible
has been so wrong for so long and this
is the fight between republicans and
democrats this is a fight among the home
team we speak with fox news sunday host
chris wallace and i'm carol markowitz
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
parents are passionate about their kids
education it's obvious from the growing
numbers at school board meetings around
the country but it's not just parents a
new fox news poll finds 73 percent of
registered voters say they're extremely
or very concerned about what schools
teach only inflation political divisions
and health care rank higher and for
republicans and independents it's third
on that list instead of fourth a hot
button issue on capitol hill too nobody
has a right to threaten his or her
fellow citizens with violence new york
congressman jerry nadler among the
democrats thanking attorney general
merrick garland during a house judiciary
committee hearing on thursday for his
response to concerns about threats
against school officials garland moving
to establish a direct line of
communication involving the fbi and
federal prosecutors after the national
school boards association wrote to
president biden asking for help
appearing to liken parents to domestic
terrorists the letter mentioned multiple
federal agencies and laws including the
patriot act ohio republican congressman
steve chabot one example of a so-called
terrorist incident was a parent merely
questioning whether school board members
had earned their high school diplomas
garland telling lawmakers the justice
department supports and defends the
rights of parents to complain as
vociferously as they wish i can't
imagine any circumstance in which the
patriot act would be used in the
circumstances
of parents complaining about their
children nor can i imagine a
circumstance where they would be labeled
as domestic terrorism he says the goal
is trying to prevent violence and the
threat of violence which he says is a
rising problem not just for school
officials but for election workers
judges and police and he rejects any
suggestion that the biden justice
department is not acting independently i
was dumbfounded really betsy devos
served as education secretary in the
trump administration we know parents
have been upset with what
has been going on in many of their
children's schools and they have been
rightfully so going to speak to their
school boards and
raising issues and asking questions
and and then when learning that these
national political organizations
left-wing political organizations have
been meeting in the white house
and a few days later a letter appears
from the national school board
association
asking for a department of justice
investigation into and help with
uh you know these alleged problems in a
whole bunch of states
and then doj comes out with uh an
intention to investigate these
you know quote unquote problems it it
sounds more like the kgb than it does
the federal bureau of investigation and
what should be happening in our country
i mean to the extent that some board
members and other school officials have
been threatened
letters or notes for instance things on
social media things that happen not in
school board meetings but other settings
um that doesn't seem like the kind of
thing that has always
happened i mean did it happen before we
just didn't hear about it you know how
concerned should the country be about
that
well certainly if there are any
incidents of violence or threats of
violence those should be addressed but
you know that's what local law
enforcement is for
we don't need to call in the fbi you
know our national um
uh police force to go and and take uh
take you know residents in places where
these
isolated incidents are happening
the the reality is that it appears on
multiple levels to be simply an effort
to intimidate and silence parents
that uh the system doesn't want to hear
from parents they don't want to have to
deal with them and so this is their way
of doing it and the biden administration
has gone right along with it
certainly they deny that there's any
sort of overt effort in that direction
but they're definitely being accused by
republicans at least of weaponizing the
justice department on this issue it's
very interesting that five days after a
the national school board association
sends this letter that doj takes action
and you know having spent four years in
washington i can tell you that doj
hasn't acted that quickly on anything
that i had experience with um so it it
really does call into question the
motives and the reasoning for this type
of overreach and overreaction and uh and
i you know i i feel for parents who are
rightfully concerned about what they're
what they're seeing
and hearing about their kids education
and they they have every right to be
involved to ask questions to advocate
for their own children they're the ones
that know and love them the best there
are
some suggestions that
it may be backfiring if the intent is to
have a chilling effect that it may be
backfiring i know at the hearing
before the house judiciary committee
ohio congressman jim jordan said that
he thinks this memo from the attorney
general was really the last straw i
think it was the catalyst for a great
awakening that is just getting started
pilots at southwest airlines the
chicago police union parents at school
board meetings americans are pushing
back
because americans value freedom and then
you have the governor's race in virginia
where education and specifically
parental involvement is
seems to be the reason at least one
reason that the race is tightening and
that the democrat terry mcauliffe has
lost some ground
even though he says his comments about
parents and education were taken out of
context
what do you see happening are you
concerned that
it is going to start to stifle the
discourse or do you think this will go
in the other direction and light a fire
under more parents well i do think it's
going to lead to more parents
speaking up and engaging and
really making sure that their children
and their children's educations are in
line with what they thought they were
and what they want them to be
we have to remember that it was the
national teachers unions that kept
schools shut down for over a year
they
bullied the cdc into changing their in
the mask guidance
as a result we have millions of kids who
have fallen further and further and
further behind in their education and
who today many have of
whom have
mental health issues and challenges
because of the lengthy shutdowns and
isolation and so i think parents are
rightfully engaged in awakening around a
system that has for too long served
itself
and has uh and and is really um
very much controlled by and responsi you
know the democrat party is very
controlled by and responsive to these
national political organizations and i
think terry mcauliffe former governor
mcauliffe is very out of touch with
what's actually going on at the
grassroots level with parents and
you know i think it is an issue that is
going to be very decisive in that race a
lot of this uh the protests from parents
if you will
hinge on critical race theory the the
school board letter mentions that
specifically um it also denies that it's
actually being taught as a curriculum in
schools uh they call it propaganda in
that letter that they sent to the
president
is it propaganda is there a chance that
parents are overreacting in some way on
this issue well i think it's every
parent's right to ask the questions and
we know for a fact that this uh this
theory and these kinds of curriculums
have been turning up in schools across
the country it is absolutely false for
them to say anything otherwise and in
fact the national teacher national
education association actually has part
as part of their platform uh support for
teaching this curriculum and has
actually designated funds to
defend and protect teachers if they are
questioned or challenged when teaching
it
is there
a way to achieve a better outcome on
race and awareness in schools than what
is happening
with so-called critical race theory what
should be happening
in education along those lines in your
view if anything well
absolutely we should be teaching
accurate american history
the good and the bad parts but we should
also
be continuing to look toward and
appreciating the ways in which our
country has continued to
strive to become a more perfect union uh
you know the the critical race theory
and the other
types of curriculums that basically pit
uh people against one another based on
their race is simply self-destructive
and uh it it really is a part of the
whole marxist playbook to try to get all
of us to hate one another more and to
either be pitted as an oppressor or
one who is oppressed
that is not what america was founded on
and that is not what we aspire to be i
know you've also always been a big
advocate for school choice could this
lead to a renewed push in that direction
well it absolutely is and we've seen to
date
21 or maybe 22 states that have
expanded existing programs or created
new programs just since the first of the
year
and more and more parents understanding
what we mean when we talk about
school choice and education freedom
parents who a year and a half ago never
would have considered themselves
interested in
this subject have found very little
control or power over their kids
education this last year and a half and
are today demanding more and and i think
that's good and it's healthy and i think
it's going to ultimately lead to better
opportunities more choices and a lot
more positive outcomes particularly for
the kids who are most disadvantaged
because those are the ones for whom the
school choice programs have basically
been targeted in in the states for for
many many years
one other quick question because i know
you have to go betsy devos
after leading the education department
for four years i'm just wondering what
concerns you most about the state of
schools right now you've mentioned the
the long-standing achievement gap uh the
pandemic certainly didn't help and we're
still living in the pandemic what
concerns me but what also i'm very
optimistic about is the fact that this
system
uh which has been indefensible for so so
many years uh is really at the at the
brink of crumbling and i think that's
ultimately going to be the best thing
for every kid in this country if we can
go to a place where families are making
those decisions and they're empowered to
choose the right fit for their kids
education the outcomes for kids at every
level are going to be so much better
than they have been for a long long time
former education secretary betsy devos
thank you so much for your time thank
you so much lisa
[Music]
this is carol markowitz with your fox
news commentary coming up
house speaker nancy pelosi says
democrats in the end will agree on their
big social spending plan and pass
president biden's economic agenda
although it's a smaller bill it's still
historic
transformational and will make an
enormous difference in the lives of
america's working families top senate
republican mitch mcconnell the american
people would be a lot better off if this
reckless tax and spending package never
passed president biden says democrats
are going to surprise people who've said
his agenda was dead on arrival but it's
taking months of inter-party negotiation
i have to say i've watched a lot of
bills and a lot of negotiations and you
know when they say it's dead it
oftentimes isn't dead and i don't think
this bill is dead chris wallace is the
host of fox news sunday but it's just
astonishing the things that come up i
mean the first one was it turned out we
we found out at the end of last month
when there was this hard deadline of the
end of september that joe manchin and
the senate democratic leader chuck
schumer had signed a document in july
which laid out what manchin's points
were and none of this had ever been told
to anybody in the house of the senate
and you know it would have saved a lot
of time now as we approach another
deadline at the end of october we're
hearing the kirsten cinema again like
everybody else the 50th democratic vote
the senator from arizona is saying i
don't want to raise taxes on
corporations and i don't want to wait
raise taxes on the wealthy and she's
blowing up the entire plan that joe
biden has been talking about for months
as to how to pay for this so
i guess i'm just shocked
that
the debate over what is possible
has been so wrong for so long and this
isn't a fight between republicans and
democrats this is a fight among the home
team and they still can't even get their
parameters great let alone an agreement
yeah and if senator cinema was going to
be against these tax hikes from the very
beginning like you said where was she in
july and a lot of her fellow democrats
are just frustrated with her and say
what okay fine what do you want senator
cinema
well she's talking about not attacks on
the wealthy but attacks on the super
wealthy which is a tax on billionaires
and then you know some kind of obscure
tax not just raising tax rates on
corporations i i have real questions you
know they're taking slim this down from
three and a half trillion to two
trillion which is still
a very much a heavyweight position
they're saying there's a real question
as to whether they could fund that with
the kind of pay for she's talking about
so again i don't understand why the
white house has been talking about
certain things for months
if cinema and she says she has made it
clear to the white house where she
stands on these issues
so you're going to have to have some
trade-offs i mean maybe you get free
pre-k but not free community college
that's something president biden uh
hinted at at some of these meetings he's
had recently with senators bernie
sanders wants vision and dental added to
medicare other senators say no well-off
people are on medicare too and they
don't need these subsidies so let's save
some money there so there's besides the
the top line figure they're still within
that policy things to work out
yeah but honestly
two trillion dollars is i mean if you
can't work out a deal for two trillion
dollars it's you know it's not a choice
between two trillion and three and a
half trillion it could be a trace
between two trillion and nothing and i
don't understand anybody on the
democratic side who would say well i'm
going to block this 2 trillion because
i'd rather have nothing than the two
trillion dollars yes you're right a lot
of the stuff is going to get scaled back
but if you would said at the beginning
of the year you're going to pass a big
covert relief though you're going to
pass a trillion dollar infrastructure
bill and a 2 trillion social tax and
spend bill i think most people would
have said
you know most democrats
including the most liberal people would
say that's fantastic so the idea that
they're now grousing about the idea that
it's going to come down
to two trillion dollars i mean i
understand it from a negotiating point
of view you want to hold on your to your
position but if they end up with i'm
trying to think two uh four
five more than five trillion dollars in
new spending uh in a single year
i think most people would say i'm going
to take that and go home
senate republicans have once again
blocked this voting rights legislation
they call it a power grab
so once again you have some democrats
saying let's just kill the filibuster
rule just for this and maybe you see
that again in a couple of months with
the debt ceiling will anything be enough
for joe manchin and the other senators
who like the status quo
uh say okay we have to pass this and
hold their nose and consider what they
call in the senate the nuclear option
well
here's the problem with that that you
know you take your step you're one
very
you you think muted step
it just opens the door so
in other words and the best example is
that is what happened on judges which is
in when barack obama was president they
had a democratic president and a
democratic senate and then senate
democratic majority leader harry reid
said you know what republicans keep
blocking on a filibuster a lot of the
president's appointees to lower courts
the the court of appeals and the
district court not the supreme court so
we will just change the rule
and say that there's no filibuster on
those well you know what happens donald
trump comes in mitch mcconnell is the
senate majority leader and he changes
the rule so there's no filibuster for
supreme court justices and you end up
with three trump appointees to the court
my point being that you know if if the
democrats were able to convince joe
manchin and kirsten cinema and blow up
the the filibuster oh we're just going
to do it for voting rights well who's to
say that the republicans aren't just
going to do it for tax cuts or just do
it for
uh
a border wall i you know the point is
every time you go down that slope and
open the door the other side when they
get back the majority is going to bust
it wide open and say well this is the
issue that we need to blow it up for
an election for governor in two states
in a week and a half new jersey governor
phil murphy he's a democrat he's
expected to keep his job at the polls or
anywhere close to accurate it's a
virginia race that has a lot of
democrats pretty nervous
and rightly so uh
mcauliffe has had a lead of between
three and five points there's a new poll
out he's flat out tied uh it's so
interesting uh living in washington i
see a lot of the ads because they're on
local dctv which includes northern
virginia if you watch the mcauliffe ads
you would think he's running against
donald trump you barely hear about glenn
younkin the republican opponent it's all
about donald trump and you know
understandably so given the fact that
that
as i say biden beat trump by 10 points a
year ago uh youncan doesn't talk about
trump at all he's really focusing on a
lot of suburban issues because that's
where republicans underperformed last
year particularly education
it's a really close race but i will say
this you know look there are individual
personalities they're individual issues
but if terry mcauliffe the former
governor of virginia a democrat loses in
a state that is trended from red to
purple to a pretty good shade of blue
right now if he loses in that state in a
week from tuesday
uh
democrats are going to just be scared to
death they'll be scared about biden
they'll be scared about the democratic
agenda
inflation
immigration some of their positions on
education
taxes spending
um
there's going to be real fear and
loathing in the democratic party if
terry mcauliffe
loses on november third
this latest fox poll has president biden
losing a lot of his approval in the
economy or on the economy down 11 in
just a month people seem to be blaming
him for the higher prices and the supply
chain stuff and concerns about christmas
presents not showing up on time is that
fair what could he what could he be
doing better
well yeah i think it is fair to the
extent first of all
you know presidents
get undue credit when things are going
well undue blame when things are going
badly but you know particularly on the
inflation issue which i think you could
talk about more than the supply chain
which has a lot of factors in terms of
shipping and what's going on at ports
and you know you could say that they
should have been
onto it quicker than they seem to have
been but
inflation they have just been wrong
about i mean how long how long has it
been that the the white house has been
kind of uh
dismissing the inflation and so how many
times we heard the word transitory and
it's not that bad and it's a sign of
growth and all of that
uh and now they're starting to take it
seriously because you know i was at the
gas station here in dc the other day
regular was over five dollars a gallon
uh that gets your attention you know if
it suddenly costs 10 or 15 20 more to
fill up your car
i don't care who you are and you know if
it costs that much more to get me or
to buy your children's shoes and we're
talking about double-digit inflation for
all of those
you know that
you feel that in your pocketbook and you
want to blame somebody and you know who
who's the most convenient person to
blame sure
former president trump finally says he's
starting this new media company
trump media and technology group that's
tmtg you've seen a lot of people on
twitter say that reminds them of the
acronym for teenage mutant ninja turtles
and they're making up
logos for him uh the first thing is this
new social media app which is something
the president has complained about a
long time even before he was banned from
twitter
it's a lot of work i wonder if he can
take it off
i don't know i mean
you know he's been trying and he
obviously feels
look he had a hundred million followers
but among all his platforms facebook and
twitter and the various white house
accounts and his private accounts you
know he had a direct line
to the
the the smartphone of a hundred million
people and that line has been cut off
and he has to go through filters to get
that information his message out to
people so i can understand
why he takes it seriously that i have no
idea whether he can pull it off
logistically and and uh you know whether
i i will say this about him he still has
a tremendous following tens of millions
of people and if he is able to make it
work and put a platform out there that
you know people could have real access
to
you know it's it's like uh field of
dreams if he builds it they will come
yeah i mean he certainly has a built-in
audience for it okay after the social
media app it's supposed to come in the
first quarter next year then they're
gonna try to put together this what they
call an over-the-top tv app you know
like fox nation it's a video on demand
thing uh so chris have you been
approached to leave fox to work for tmtg
it might be too early to talk about it i
i you know
i haven't checked my emails in the last
20 minutes so i can't act definitively
say no but
given that the president continues the
former president to uh go after me as i
like to say you know for a landlord i'm
quite pleased at the amount of space i
occupy rent free in his head
chris wallace hosted fox news sunday
thanks buddy thank you chris
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
a retired teacher has gone viral not for
doing a dance or being an influencer but
for promoting kindness
tony garcia may consider himself a quote
old retired teacher who knows not of
certain things but to more than a
hundred thousand people on facebook he
has a message well worth sharing garcia
is an author and former teacher from
fort collins colorado in a post that's
now gone viral garcia wrote he doesn't
understand quote influencers youtubers
and tick talkers but he says he wants to
present another challenge of good old
school lessons
the most important among them he says to
be a good and kind human being the post
came about after he had a conversation
with someone he used to teach with about
the sometimes violent social media
challenges that can target teachers and
school property garcia addressed viral
challenges in his post writing quote it
takes much more courage and strength to
be a loving caring person than it does
to vandalize a bathroom parents and
students are sending garcia videos of
kids engaged in acts of kindness one
school is taking his challenge literally
he told fox news a principal sent him a
message that said she used the letter as
a morning announcement for her twelve
hundred students as they participate in
a tick-tock challenge to make a positive
difference in the lives of others
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
carol markowitz
what's on your mind in a coddled america
a holiday involving costumes and candy
is offensive last week bf day elementary
school in seattle decided to cancel
their halloween parade over quote equity
concerns it's as if the people in charge
sit around thinking what joy can we
strip from the lives of american
children today the joy sucking is bad
enough but getting rid of holidays is
also a way to further divide us and
limit our celebrations together the
schools say they're canceling halloween
events because kids may not be able to
afford costumes the better way to
address equity concerns would be to find
a way to get costumes to children in
need not cancel the event for everyone
that's the problem with the people in
charge of schools and the equity
obsession it never leads to more for the
marginalized it only leads to less for
all it's not just halloween either
several schools in michigan took it a
step further and in their quest for
inclusion cancelled halloween but also
valentine's day apparently valentine's
day led to hurt feelings if a child
didn't get a valentine but also that
some families are uncomfortable
celebrating love schools have been
systematically getting rid of all
holidays for years now
mother's day and father's day have been
cut out at school in support of kids who
might not have a mother or a father
father-daughter dances have been
cancelled over gender issues
thanksgiving has been sidelined of
course columbus day never stood a chance
the randolph board of education in
morris township new jersey isn't taking
any chances in june they decided to
rename all holidays on the school
calendar and label them simply days off
quote if we don't have anything on the
calendar we don't have to have anyone
have hurt feelings or anything like that
and quote board member doreen roche said
that's true but if we need 100
participation to celebrate anything even
a generic day off might be offensive it
might be safer to write a paragraph on
the non-denominational non-exclusionary
day off and how it doesn't actually mean
anything and no offense was intended
removing the holidays is a method to
divide us from each other and keep us
apart
taking away events like halloween
parades because not everyone celebrates
just limits the way that we connect to
each other
as a little immigrant kid in brooklyn
halloween was a magical event where all
the kids in the neighborhood ran free
marveling in their full buckets of candy
and showing off their individuality
through their costumes
everyone was included if they wanted to
be
my jewish kids have learned christmas
carols and music class exchanged cards
on saint valentine's day painted candles
on diwali and ate dumplings on chinese
new year at their new york city public
schools
their israeli-born cousins would bring
in sufkanyat powdered donuts to explain
hanukkah to the kids in their class
we used to understand that in our
melting pot of a country not everything
could be for everyone
the aim to cancel out anything
celebratory until every single person
can participate leads to a dull life and
a fractured country this is carol
markowitz i'm a columnist at the new
york post and fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes